Hello and welcome to staying
awake i have a sleeping disorder
i can't tell the difference between
my waking life and dreams hello and
we'll catch you on you're
bloody useless stevie steven
i can't tell the difference
thank you that's the contact
lens hope you find it thanks
yeah oh my god you're alive what's
wrong with you mark why did you call me
embrace the chaos
Welcome back everyone marvel finally dropped their
moon knight trailer video so we'll break it down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs here and i'll
explain what's going on how this fits into marvel
phase four but i will be doing videos for all the
episodes so be sure to subscribe to get them all
it is going to be hardcore in a way you
haven't seen since netflix daredevil episodes
as i say during the trailer it's going to
premiere during march 30th we'll just start at the
beginning of the trailer footage and go through
shot by shot talking about easter eggs as we go
along and i will explain moon knight's backstory
and who the other characters are like who ethan
hawk's villain is and who werewolf by knight
is which is the character that he's beating up
in the bathroom when he's in his full moon knight
superhero costume moonite the character debuted in
the werewolf by night comics which is why werewolf
by night is such a big crossover character in the
moon knight series and marvel is doing a separate
disney plus halloween special for werewolf by
night later this year also no coincidence
that they're releasing the trailer tonight
during a full moon big werewolf by night easter
egg but they don't really give you a ton of the
story during this trailer it's just meant to kind
of introduce you to the character and the idea of
his multiple personalities he has dissociative
identity disorder so when we see him in the
trailer here in bed and he's throwing that rubik's
cube up that's meant to be a metaphor for the way
he changes between multiple personalities and he
doesn't always have control of that like later in
the trailer he's talking to someone on the phone
that might be a version of marlene from the comics
who's his love interest who calls him mark spector
on the call but he is in a steven grant persona
so he doesn't know who mark specter is like
why did you call me mark my name is stephen
he has four different personalities five if you
count the moon knight persona when he's in the
full-on superhero costume acting as moon knight
he was born mark spector but then after he becomes
moon knight because he wants to use his powers
to fight crime he develops a bunch of different
personalities steven grant is one of those it's
like this gruff cab driver he's like a matches
malone type of character so what oscar isaac said
he did to differentiate between the different
personas so that you know who you're watching
like which persona he is when he's on screen
he uses a different voice for each different
persona so when he's talking to this woman
here and she's kind of chiding him for not being
a good employee he's in the steven grant persona
but it sounds like they've changed some of his
alternate personalities just a little bit like
this version of steven grant does not seem like
a gruff cab driver what winds up happening though
is that eventually after time because he's jumping
between different personalities so much he begins
to lose the ability to distinguish between them
in what's real and what's fake so he doesn't know
who the real person is like is he really mark
spector pretending to be moon knight or is he
really moon knight pretending to be mark spector
or say stephen grant pretending to be mark spector
or mark spector pretending to be stephen grant so
that's what he's talking about in the trailer when
he says i have a sleeping disorder the memories of
the things that he does when he's in these other
personas feel kind of like dreams to him the
reason why the marvel studios logo is rotating
like this like the custom version of the logo
is meant to represent the changing phases of the
moon because obviously in the trailer when he's
fighting werewolf by night that would have to be
during a full moon in the whole ideas his powers
are tied to the phases of the moon so he's most
powerful during a full moon in the original comics
mark spector started out as a mercenary and then
he obviously became moon i developed the alternate
personalities including stephen grant so it's not
totally clear in this trailer here if when he's
walking into this museum if he's an archaeologist
and they've just changed his backstory a
little bit or if he's just using the stephen
grant persona to get more information about what's
going on at the museum i would expect a few minor
changes to his backstory but if it's not clear
in the trailer footage when he's in these clothes
all the scenes he's in the steven grant persona
when he starts to see visions of himself in the
moon knight costume that's just you witnessing
his dissociative identity disorder manifesting
this is the actual Khonsu god appearing to him in
this hallway here the whole idea is that he has a
psychic connection with moon knight and that's how
he grants him his powers so if you're not familiar
with Khonsu he's not actually the egyptian moon
god that's just what he pretends to be he used
to be worshipped by the egyptian people as the
moon god he's actually part of a group called the
elder gods who were banished to this little pocket
dimension called the other void and he can't enter
the main marvel universe but it's very easy for
him to communicate psychically with people so from
a young age conscious believes that mark spector
has a fragile enough mind that it would be easy
enough for him to use him as his finger puppet
avatar on earth so Khonsu is not meant to be this
benevolent god he has no interest in actually
helping anyone but himself and when he anoints
mark specter moon knight giving him all his powers
he basically makes him his avatar of vengeance
on earth enacting his vengeance on whoever Khonsu
wants to get revenge against and a lot of times
that puts him at odds with the other marvel hero
characters but mark spector himself does try to
use his powers for good when he can most of moon
knight's actual powers and abilities are just
like upgraded versions of captain america's powers
enhanced strength speed durability healing factor
all tied to the faces of the moon so he's
stronger faster during a full moon than during
other periods one of the other cool abilities
that they've given him recently because of the
logic and the way that Khonsu's powers work as
he gives them to him lunar base powers is that
he can actually control thor's hammer like he can
take thor's hammer from him without being worthy
because it's created from uru metal which is a
lunar ore probably not going to see them do that
in the mcu anytime soon but it would be cool to
see him interact with some of the other avengers
because he does have some spider-man level quips
in him so when they have this funny moment in the
elevator where he feels like he's seeing this
hallucination of Khonsu it's probably Khonsu
trying to get him to do something and mark spectre
just not completely being on board with it yet but
if it wasn't clear nobody else can see Khonsu
doctor strange and other really powerful marvel
characters might be able to detect that somebody
else is speaking to mark spector psychically but
it is only a psychic connection so Khonsu cannot
physically manifest in the main mcu universe
in this scene of him creeping through the museum
at night when he passes this exhibit there's
a statue of atum or almond raw that's actually
Khonsu the god's father within their pantheon of
gods that they come from my early theory is that
ethan hawk is actually playing the sun king and
he is the avatar on earth of conscious father and
it winds up being this war between avatars in this
war between gods at the same time it's not clear
exactly what's going on with this phone call i do
like the idea that he has an old-school flip phone
that really gives you a flashback to the early
2000s love the alligator wallpaper here too kind
of reminds you of alligator loki even though there
isn't a huge connection to the loki series in the
kang multiverse war this has a bigger connection
with say like doctor strange multiverse of
madness the more supernatural characters
like the marvel blade movie with mahershala
ali or kit harrington's black knight character
sure you're ready for that mr whitman
there have been rumors that they're going to cross
over in the moonlight series like moon knight will
eventually show up either like in the blade movie
but eventually definitely avengers 5 and bigger
supernatural crossover movies the way ethan hawke
described his villain character is that he's kind
of like a cult leader like you see everyone in
the street bowing to him here that's kind of
like the sun king in the moon knight comics and it
also seems like when he's talking to moon knight
he knows what's going on with him more than anyone
else like he sees chaos inside him and tells him
to embrace that as if he's seeing something in
moon knight that he also sees inside himself
this seems like him inside a mental institution
which happened several times in the moonlight
comics the scene of him in the car seems like him
switching between personalities and not realizing
how he got here the egyptian pyramids just
to help place you where this is all happening
this scene actually seems like him getting ready
to get his powers like it seems like he's inside
one of the pyramids or one of the archaeology dig
sites standing at the base of conscious statue but
this is him inside his mark spectre persona but
here when he's running with this bag here where
it seems like this crazy look on his face with
the same outfit from before this is him back
in the stephen grant persona and this is the scene
of him switching between the stephen grant persona
to the full-on mark spector moon knight persona
with the robes just manifesting out of him that's
why i say when he's stephen grant he's already got
his powers so this gives you a good look for what
it's going to look like on screen just visualizing
the way his powers work then like i said this is
him in a bathroom in a completely separate scene
just beating the hell out of werewolf by night
i like the way that they've done the visual
effect on his eyes too like the glowing white eyes
then they just have a little tag scene at the
end of the trailer with him jumping across the
rooftops at night against the backdrop of the moon
but just to explain werewolf by night because he's
actually going to be a pretty big character in
the series and moving forward in marvel phase
4 as well werewolves in the marvel universe
lycanthropy however you want to think about it
originated in the darkhold which i know will
sound familiar because we just saw it in the
doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
and during wandavision with scarlet witch
it's a book of chaos magic so i guess you could
say that werewolves were created by chaos magic
the main version of werewolf by knight jack
russell who we're going to see during the series
is a descendant of the first known werewolf who
had a lot of adventures featuring the darkhold of
the high evolutionary the wundergarh mountains
where scarlet witch and quicksilver were born
the first time he ran into moon knight was
when moon knight debuted for the very first
time so it was inside the werewolf by night
comics werewolf by night number 32 in 1975 so
moonite was originally a villain he was hired by
this criminal organization called the committee
who hired him to kill werewolf by knight who was
the hero of that story but when marvel introduced
the character they never intended for moon knight
to be like a really big deal he was just gonna be
a one-off villain in this werewolf by night comic
book he became so popular that marvel was like
please bring the character back so they put him
in a bunch of backup stories in the hulk magazine
way back in the day which was intended for more
mature readers they eventually gave him his own
comic book title in the early 80s they also put
him on the defenders the dr strange version of the
defenders with hulk and a bunch of other different
characters not the marvel netflix defenders roster
he's mostly shown up in big supernatural stories
but he's been a big avengers crossover story he
joined the avengers at one point also the midnight
suns because we're going to be getting a version
of ghost rider soon we know we have blade and
just a bunch of other supernatural characters
that will be showing up really soon if you spotted
any big easter eggs in the trailer that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below
in the comments if you have any big requests
too just let me know i will be doing more moon
knight bonus videos before the series comes out
everyone click here for my eternals deleted
scene with kit harington's black knight character
and click here for my eternals deleted
scenes video for thanos and star fox
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!